I used to want to save the world.
But the closer you get
the more you see the great darkness within.
What is your mission?
To stop the war.
What war?
The war to end all wars.
I cannot stand by while innocent lives are lost.
Be careful, Diana.
Who is this woman?
She is my, umm... secretary, Sir.
She's a very good secretary.
It is our sacred duty to defend the world
and that's what I'm going to do.
I used to want to save the world.
This beautiful place.
But the closer you get
the more you see the great darkness whitin.
I learned this the hard way
a long, long time ago.
What is your mission?
To stop the war.
What war?
The war to end all wars.
Weapons far deadlier than you can ever imagine.
I walk in the hours.
Wherever you are, you are in more danger than you think.
I cannot stand by while innocent lives are lost.
Be careful, Diana.
Who is this woman?
She is my, umm... secretary, Sir.
She's a very good secretary.
It is our sacred duty to defend the world
and that's what I'm going to do.
Diana!
How could a woman possibly fight in this?
Fight? We use our principles.
Although, I am not opposed to engaging in
a bit of fisticuffs should the occasion arise.